my point has always been to to say what
I think people believe but are too
scared to say for reasons of either
direct political correctness or indirect
political correctness is a slight
difference between the two and also to
make people laugh or even less my job is
to is to is to amuse for that I usually
get called a racist and a homophobe
because I have made jokes about black
people before and indeed gay people but
I like to think of myself in a very real
sense as an equal opportunities [ __ ]
someone who will offend everybody
including you know the people I come
from up in the northeast of England and
people who live in Brighton especially
maybe people who live in Brighton and
French people and everyone they are all
in there I don't think I think everybody
has the right to have the piss taken out
of them including me I think that's a
beautiful thing about the French and
that people say you can't take the piss
out black people gay people but French
accept the changes you know used to be
like that about the Welsh I tried that a
couple of years ago it wasn't it was one
of the least offensive things I've ever
said in my life I happen to mention that
there was a paucity of vowels in the
Welsh language which isn't a terribly
original observation nor a terribly
funny one and Damon do lolly and the
Welsh language society said it's
important we must stick to freedom of
speech freedom of speech is the most
important thing but we must stop people
generating hate about our language
generating hate about your [ __ ]
knocking the nog language Thomas and
your tank engines Isle of Man isn't it
he actually reported to their police and
said can we investigate this to see if
this is a race hate crime suggesting
that there are not many vowels in the
Welsh language and the thing which
struck me was that he was actually the
police commissioner for North Wales oh
wow and he referred it and presumably
you know he should have been
investigating for waste wasting police
time just so so we'll be careful within
a year or two the French you're not
gonna weigh with the French we'll be
left with having to pick on tiny
minority countries yeah
valid yeah yeah you mispronounce the
name I quite like the you clarified that
it was one specific question because
initially you said they called and I
just had this image in my head of like
the whole of support yeah yeah because
I've got loads of letters in from people
saying from from people in Carmarthen
and Cardiff and real say God I'm so
sorry when did we lose our sense of
humor you know
[Music]
so no II of course not it's that liberal
elite with their vested interests who
desperately desire a sense of victimhood
and I suppose they are victims because
they're sick of [ __ ]
[Music]